cette augmentation elle creuse une
nouvelle fois les inégalités en pesant
plus lourd sur les propriétaires de
petites surfaces par exemple type T2 en
effet tout le monde le sait ici les 20
premiers mètres carrés d'un bien sont
toujours les plus chers et la surface
supplémentaire bénéficie d'une taxation
allégé déjà en 2021 quelle que soit la
ville la taxe foncière apportée au mètre
carré est 36 % plus élevée en moyenne
pour les petits logement comparé au T4
et plus n doute que cette augmentation
va placer les bailleurs sociaux qu'il
soit public ou privé dans une situation
financière très délicate pire si aucune
action n'est entreprise ces difficultés
se traduiront inévitablement par des
répercussions sur les locataires
monsieur le ministre vous portez au
travers vous le gouvernement seul la
responsabilité de cette hausse record
depuis 1986 et l'envolet de la taxe
foncière des communes donc oui ce débat
est un moment de vérité mes chers
collègues partagez ma stupeur quand la
Première ministre affirmait que
l'envolet de la taxe foncière était dû
je la cite une décision des
collectivités
territoriales les relations état
collectivité ciment de la République
souffre de ce type de communication qui
je le dis méprise la réalité les faits
et les responsabilité ce que nous vous
demandons c'est de la sincérité cessz de
nous dire que vous allez refonder un
Pact entre les échelons politiques du
territoire quand vous vous évertuz à
vous défausser sur les élus locaux en
première ligne face à leur population